im oberbayerischen erding baut die stadt
dieses neue verwaltungsgebäude steht
genau vis a vis vom historischen rathaus
die beiden häuser trennen gerade mal 28
meter kein problem da rüber zu kommen
sollte man meinen doch um die beiden
gebäude miteinander zu verbinden hat die
stadt eine wahrhaft extravagante idee
unter der landshuter straße wird
demnächst ein behörden tunnel gebaut
ich finde das also irgendwie schon eine
frechheit dass man bei dem rathaus
setzen da diese parameter und der tunnel
muss da gibt es einen zebrastreifen bei
der fußgänger über kommen und das können
wir leiten das wird stroß geld ich halte
hier komplett sinnlos weil wir in der
heutigen zeit ja genügend möglichkeiten
hätten drahtlos oder auch fußgänger los
die daten zu übertragen weil das
historische rathaus aus allen nähten
platzt baut die stadt seit 2017 diesen
erweiterungsbau
aber wie sollen die mitarbeiter von der
landshuter straße 1 zur hausnummer 4
kommen etwa über den zebrastreifen in
der tempo 20 zone auf gar keinen fall
denn auf dem oberirdischen weg droht der
verlust von daten so die stadt damit
sowas nicht passiert beschließt der
stadtrat im vergangenen jahr mit großer
mehrheit den bau des tunnels der sei für
die verwaltung zwingend notwendig
inklusive aller nebenkosten werden für
den tunnelbau etwa 1,1 millionen euro
fällig in zeiten von internet und
digitalisierung eine beachtliche
investition
ich halte den tunnel für völlig
überflüssig auch die argumentation
sonst könnten weiß ich nicht was
datendateien oder aktenordner viel mehr
verschwinden das ist natürlich auch
unsinn ich habe einfach kein verständnis
dafür es ist eine menge geld das da
verwendet wird aber warum muss man für
28 meter extra einen tunnel bauen im
erdinger rathaus kann man die aufregung
nicht verstehen schriftlich heißt es
befinden sich behörden oder
unternehmenssitze in benachbarten
gebäuden sind direkte verbindungen
absolut üblich eine oberirdische
verbindung scheidet in unserem fall aus
denkmalschutzrechtlichen gründen aus aha
der gang über die straße ist für die
stadt also keine direkte verbindung und
weil eine brücke nicht möglich ist gräbt
man sich durchs erdreich
das sind gelder die wir alles aufbringen
und dann für solche sache ausgegeben da
halte ich dich davon
das ist nicht in ordnung wenn sie das
machen müssen ausreden kann man sie
nämlich am ende zahlen wäre doch wenn im
april die landshuter straße aufgerissen
wird beginnt auch der bau des tunnels
im sommer soll alles fertig sein dann
werden die menschen in erding wissen was
sie die unterirdische querung
tatsächlich gekostet hat